Kids have bundles of energy,
but they need the right snacks to keep them going
that's why I give my kids,
Fruit-E Bars
*laughs*
"Why am I not surprised that you haven't done a video on net neutrality Pewdiepie.
It's sad how much you're disconnected from regular people."
"PewDiePie, please make a video about net neutrality and spread awareness about it.
PLEASE."
"PewPie please everyone is waiting on you from the community to help make a video
about stop FCC
Taking control of net neutrality"
"Do a vid on net neutrality. Please we need you"
"I'm surprised the biggest guy on YouTube, a career in the internet, isn't just a little concerned with net neutrality
unless I'm missing something otherwise,
it would really help if someone who has access to more than 50 million subs to spread awareness through
I don't know
maybe a video PSA at least,
but you know that's just a thought.
Well carry on everybody
Have a good day"
URGENT
if you're not freaking out about net neutrality right now
You're not paying attention
listen here, okay.
I know what it's like
to have bad internet
alright
Don't come to me
being all like
uh, net neutrality and everything is gonna be bad
Ohhh
listen, everyone knows we want net neutrality.
What do you want me to say about it? Its...
been all over Internet.
It's literally been blasted.
How do you not know about this?
ehh, Your favorite youtuber has made a video about it
everyone has talked about it.
What do you want me to say about it?
First of all
in case you, for some reason, don't know what net neutrality is
let's look it up
"Net neutrality is the principle that Internet service providers
and governments regulating the internet must treat all data
on the Internet the same
and not discriminate or charge
deferentially by user, content, website, platform, application,
type of attach--
okay, I don't care
I immediately don't care
okay?
"But he isn't in the US
so unless the UK government is retarded
It doesn't affect him."
Oh!
it would seem this doesn't affect me
Suck it America.
No for real.
Sorry,
okay, the memes got ahead of me
of course It's a serious issue
of course it is
let's see what--what people are saying about net neutrality
Okay here we go on
Come Onnn, ugh
come on
Still loading?
still loading
have you ever been stuck
on a really slow internet connection
-One so slow that you just can't stream video
-yes
Or you have to give up on using certain sites or apps
-because they just take too long to load?
-Yeah, yes yes
How did you know this?
well imagine that certain sites were permanently confined to a slow lane like that?
Practically they are!
While others were allowed to operate at full speed.
Oh my god!
unless
What-the-what-the-what-the-what
I already have this problem
You trying to sell me an issue that I already have?
No, thank you.
Okay.
It would be like paying to board earlier for an airplane
But for just about anything that you do online
I love paying...
extra, so I can get it earlier
it's great!
I don't have to stand in line with all the weirdos
The idea that Internet service providers
shouldn't be allowed to discriminate against
or grant preferential treatment
to particular sites
also sorry,
but--eh--stripe
you can't wear stripe on camera
like did no one tell you that?
without net neutrality
broadband providers like Comcast, Charter
as well as mobile carriers like, AT&T and Verizon
Could slow Netflix to a crawl
in order to keep you paying for their television package
Get that
excuse me
get that man out of my face
basically a world without net neutrality
Might mean that you have to pay more
to access the Internet content you want
but it could also crush innovation
because without a level playing field
New apps and services won't be able to compete with entrenched companies
like anyone gives a shit
come on let's get real here
people want net neutrality because they don't want the government to interfere with the internet
ATATATATA
Not so fast
Pewds from the past here, made a big mistake here
my microphone stopped working.
I'm sorry
It's late
But I feel like it's important
cuz I don't want to spread misinformation on
what's clearly already a very confusing topic
Uhhh, The FCC is a government agency
and the government wanting to repeal net neutrality
my immediate thought was
oh, okay, so
the government wants to take more control over the Internet
And that's why everyone is so outraged
when this is actually a rare case of the government saying
hey, we want less control here
and more into the ISPs
net neutrality is
the government
sort of controlling
and making sure that ISPs are held to a certain standard
that they can't block access to certain websites
and keeping the internet free and neutral,
and I think that's very, very important,
so I clearly got it wrong
and, uh
I wanted to apologize and
set the record straight
the head of FCC
also villain of the internet
Ajit Pai
has come forward to explain
Hi, I'm Ajit Pai.
I'm the chairman of the FCC
I really enjoyed the public debate about the future of the Internet
No, no
No you fucking don't
Shut the--shut the fuck up.
You're already lying
Now, Ajit Pai has been on a media campaign
to twist the public's
uh, idea of
Net neutrality
to sort of switch it around
and it's not
It's not going great for Ajit
I always tell the truth
Basing on any video with him in
and the dislike bar
so the F(CC)--so basically
For those of you who don't know
back in 2015 this whole discussion
Had already happened.
I don't know if you guys remember
Remember Kony 2012?
well, then it was Net Neutrality 2015
and here we are again, Net Neutrality 2017
--system is working
Yet Mr. Chairman you are proposing
to
undo the open internet border
Uh, what is the problem Mr. Chairman?
That you are trying to fix?
Yes! Thank you, finally.
I want the answer of this
Thank you for the question senator
Uh, I think one of the concerns that we have raised is that
these regulations might be dampening infrastructure investment
They might be, but there's no evidence of it
Well there has been evidence raised
and that's part of the reason why we are testing this proposition
in the context of the newest proposed rulemaking
some had suggested the FCC should
Simply issue a declaratory ruling
Saying that the facts in the law are so
and that's the way it's going to be
But we wanted to test this proposition in an open and public process
wha--? what--what the--what the--what the--
what are you--what are--
What are you saying?
at this rate, I'm convinced that Ajit
just wants to remove net neutrality
so he can delete all the mean comments about him on the Internet
Uh, he's been on Fox News
where they try to twist
Repealing net neutrality as a left and right issue
the mainstream
media
Maybe we should just call it call them what they are the leftist media
They're the Washington Post anyway
writes this today, sir
so they're basically trying to angle it like
oh it's the left media the--
ah those stupid leftists
when really according to
Uh, polling
everyone is against net neutrality
Is not a political left and right sort of question
a lot of celebrities have been tweeting about the FCC,
Cher
Tweeted
"Net Neutrality means Trump can change the internet
it will include less Americans not more"
I-I-I don't know. I can't read this.
This is so incoherent but
Uh, Pai replied to this saying
"Another concern I've heard is that the plan will harm
rural and low-income Americans
Cher, for example has tweeted
that the internet will include less Americans not more
if my proposal is adopted. But the opposite is true
The digital divide is all too real
too many rural and low-income Americans
are still unable to get high-speed Internet
so basically a big argument for--uh--to repeal net neutrality
is so that more people
The government can build out for more people
to get access to the Internet
so really he's just looking after all of us
Why can't the government do that without
Repealing net neutrality?
I have no idea
why is it, if that's what he wants
Why does the FCC
Want mobile data to count as broadband internet?
that idea
which is an idea that would further cut off
poor and rural areas from decent internet.
you're kind of getting--you're saying one thing
but you're showing the other
Uh, the FCC also made a
myth vs. fact to sort of
Clear out what the facts are saying that
This is the end of the Internet as we know it.
They're saying
No, that's not true
Startups will not be able to compete with Title II regulations
They're saying. No, that's not true
Internet service providers will block you from visiting the website you want to visit
and basically anything that people are saying about the--
uhmmm
about net neutrality
They're saying that's incorrect
actually, that's not how it's gonna work
But it doesn't say how?
or why?
or when?
and really I haven't seen any convincing argument for
Should we ruin something that is already clearly working fine?
It's just
"Oh more people will have access to the Internet"?
sure buddy,
sure
Since I'm re-recording this bit
I might as well add that,
since you guys told me,
the reason why Ajit thinks that
this will bring out more
Infrastructure to rural areas
is because there will be more competition, with the government interfering less.
This is all speculation
But I will say, I think it's worth mentioning that
Ajit used to work for one of the biggest internet service providers in USA
Verizon
and it sort of make you question, like
what's the motive here?
is he just helping out his buddies from his old company?
it doesn't really make sense and
I'm sure the way net neutrality is presented by a lot of
Media campaigns and that it's so bad
I'm sure it's not as bad as people are saying,
but I'm--but I also haven't seen any argument for why?
It's a good idea to repeal net neutrality
the whole thing is just absurd
no one believes a Ajit Pai and like I said
I'm convinced.
This is just his personal vendetta with the Internet at this at this--
at this point
but there as always, the memes
*smacks lips*
Is a very tasty
From this
complain all you want
it's never ever, ever, ever, gonna stop
come on, how bad can it possibly be?
How ba-a-a-ad can I be?
I'm just building the economy.
How Ba-a-a-ad can I be?
Just look at me, petting this puppy
How ba-a-a-ad can I be?
a portion of proceeds, goes to charity
How bad could I possibly be?
let's see
Sounds familiar doesn't it?
Yup I'm talking about this...
net neutrality
We need to speak up
just like everyone else says
if we don't speak up...
bye-bye fandoms
bye-bye memes
bye-bye fanart
bye-bye fanfics
God damnit
Why net neutrality is important
just imagine EA
is your internet provider
Yeah, no
my internet is so good
Support net neutrality
the Internet should be free
if you want to build out rural areas
I'm sure you can do it
without fucking with the internet.
Okay?
just leave
leave our memes alone.
Thank you